you you should update your documentation
too by the way okay
all right hello everyone welcome to
another wolf language design review part
of our language completeness and
consistency series
hold on let me just do what I was told
to do update documentation here
um
all right labeled Graphics box
okay so the uh the issue here is uh I
was asked to make plot label
um better uh to support uh uh you know
like labeled style placements uh
and I'm not really here to talk about
the the top level details of that that
that will be with Brett and Brett's not
here today he's he's out today
um but uh uh but I am working on what
the implementation looks like
um and so uh I mean the basic problem is
a plot label is awful it causes all
kinds of problems and adding uh adding a
dozen new ways to do plot label is not
something I want to do
um
and so we're trying to solve the problem
by different means
um and so essentially
what we're looking at is creating a new
box which I'm provisionally calling
label Graphics box uh and it is a thing
that uh takes in its uh and there is a
documentation if you want to open up the
documentation for it
oh I wasn't told there was maybe it
didn't exist when when we last spoke
John but uh if I'd known I would have
included the link
so yeah basically the idea is that this
is a thing that wraps a graphics or a
graphics 3D and applies labels to it
uh in a way that is more flexible but it
has the rubber banding Behavior Uh you
know the graphic style selection around
the whole of uh the label let me tell
you the thing that I'm really concerned
about okay so let me let me show you an
example sure
by the way is this showing me the new
when I can type through thing here or
not
uh no
okay
because I wasn't happy with the scene
yeah
okay see that
those labels are cut off
yeah
and and I think let's solved that yes
yes so so this is uh uh well
you know I mean there is a a more
significant discussion of how this
interacts with Graphics grid which once
again Brett's not here and I haven't
really reviewed this deeply with Brett
but uh but but the general issue is that
this is a thing that understands how big
its label is
and can react accordingly it understands
how biggest label is it understands what
it can do with resizing the graphic it
has certain rules for kind of resizing
the graphic to fit the label or or to
crop the label if the graphic is the
thing that's kind of controlling the uh
the size this sounds very good look I
mean the other problem is this is
leaving too much space you see what I'm
saying
because it's worried about the label and
so on see this place here this is
garbage yeah yeah I mean why don't you
you can take this case and just use it
as a test because I mean this if this
doesn't work I don't know why it's
leaving all this empty space but it's
wrong
do you agree it's wrong
yes
um
but there's there's a lot about the
implementation of Graphics grid that I I
can't speak with you I understand that
but the bottom line is we've got to fix
this
right I mean it's leaving too much space
and the thing that you're talking about
which I hadn't really thought about that
is a possibility seems like exactly the
right kind of construct to fix this
yeah
so go ahead so so the uh the initial
implementation of this would be looking
at uh placements that basically follow
labeled
um the you know bottom left top right et
cetera et cetera
um doesn't labeled have a have an
absolute relative you know 0.7 and
things not that I've seen in the
documentation maybe it has in certain
contexts not not as a standalone
construct that I've seen
um but but
uh you know we're anticipating that you
might want to do something like that you
might want to have a label that maybe
even partially overlaps with the graphic
and this construct is built to be able
to absorb that sort of flexibility in
the future but in terms of what we might
want to deliver in the next release we
have to keep our mission you know uh
doable in that time frame all right look
if you can solve this problem that's
already highly useful
okay okay so and you know I you know
I've written up some provisional
documentation you may not really care
you know it's it to a certain extent is
kind of an implementational detail that
you may not care deeply about designing
but I wanted to make sure we didn't get
too far no I mean the only question that
I have is this label comma pause
mechanism here which is the typical
thing that we've done in low level
functions and the high level things we
tend to use rules and things like that
more
because I think this is a low level
function this is probably what we should
use here yeah yeah yes
okay so I'll be gone uh sure yeah
okay and I've updated documentation for
this but I copied the documentation here
so you can uh so this is parent cell and
parent box
um which right now just take one
argument and uh so parent cell uh well
of
evaluation so uh which I think in this
case by the way probably my input is
dragging here something is I mean this
is a prototype built so who knows what's
going on yeah so in this case returns
failed because the evaluation cell
didn't have a parent
um uh but but
this is what would it mean so I mean
well inline cells inline cells have
parents
okay so if I say if I do the same thing
this is dragging this is not typing
properly
I don't know
well I'm telling you that so I'm just
uh uh I mean you you could just do
um you know dynamic of expression cell
I'm doing this why did that
so now if I do command
return here yeah
okay and notice it's not it's not the
inline cell that it returned it's the
text cell that was the parents so yeah
why is it in this font
uh because that is expected line cells
and text cells do
right okay they match the text font
okay so what should we be paying
attention to here uh okay okay so the
single argument forum is was there
before uh I'm proposing adding second
arguments uh uh to these functions of
the forms node today
I have no opinion what you want this for
uh so basically uh
well I mean you know basically it's
whenever you have uh uh you know usually
a user interface that's doing some kind
of you know self modification or
introspection on the things that contain
it okay you're introducing this because
you needed it for something what was the
thing you needed it for
uh
Lou
sorry we we have other solutions for the
things that we needed this for this is
the cleaner solution so for instance in
control equal there is a button that
lets you replace the control equal
interface with the parse
yeah and there's a so we need a way from
that button to uniquely determine the
Box object of the interface as a whole
we have other solutions for this
currently we use something that we call
box IDs
um but this the the parent box
particularly the fourth line item in
John's uh display here on the type comma
n would let us you know run directly to
the container that we care about
okay
great
if you if this solves that problem for
you the design looks fine to me
okay I agree
okay
um style key mapping so this uh I
started we've had this for a long time
but we didn't have any documentation
um and so I wrote up some documentation
because we want to extend it and this
was related to the equal bracket thing
that we discussed and used for
assistance where uh if if you type in an
equal you get a wolf enough a short cell
and then what you proposed is if you
type in a bracket it flips back to an
input cell but an input cell populated
with the text equal bracket
which is not something the style key
mapping can do right now
so to remind you style key mapping is
the thing that you know is you know when
you type in the initial equal it gives
you the wolf math assorted when you type
in initial star it gives you an item
cell etc etc yes
um
and so basically uh basically what I'm
proposing as a style key mapping can
take uh a full cell right hand side
what could it take before uh just a
style name
and then it would create an empty cell
of of that style seems like a no-brainer
okay
um and then the other thing I noticed
was I noticed a bit of inconsistency in
terms of uh uh that style key mapping
was using this thing called key event
um
uh but there are other places that use a
thing called menu key to be able to uh
to specify things with uh uh you know
keyboard shortcuts with with modifiers
like you know with the shift key or with
the control key or something
um
and uh it's not maybe we should
standardize uh
yeah
so if if you're okay you know we haven't
really kind of documented any real way
of doing this but I'm happy to just you
know standardize on key events start
deploying that everywhere
sounds well and to me the only thing is
you've got to continue supporting many
key because there'll be Legacy style
sheets oh sure yes yes we don't have to
document it but yes it still has to work
I agree
sounds fine to me tell me how I mean
this isn't perhaps relevant here but
percent monetization is that going to
need language support
I bet it is
by language so I'm not sure what you
mean by that I mean wolfen language
level function new functions like
for example you know percent 13 is
equivalent to or percent percent
13 times equivalent to out of -13 right
right what we're going to want is
something that is the equivalent of out
of it's not really out it's really you
know notebook previous sell such and
such but maybe we just have that maybe
yeah well and and you had suggested some
sort of previous cell sort of thing
which is on my list of things to bring
to this meeting but uh but it it's not
in today's meeting it's uh because I I I
think it needed to be a bit better
design than just previous sell bracket
bracket you need okay
uh right so you know I raised the
question which I want an answer to and
you know
uh
and also what does ondo do that's the
question
um I mean I would expect undo to undo
the effective typing in or of of you
know typing the key whatever the effect
was
just on peel so equals equals unpeals
down to equals unpeels to nothing yeah I
mean I mean if if it doesn't work now
that's just a bug it should be fixed
okay and you know the equals okay now I
press undo command Z
okay so so that's just a bug
and that's interesting because when uh I
tested it with well I guess I think I
think I did it with star
um
uh but I I think command Z actually
undid the whole thing it beeps again
just beeps interesting so unless it's
always be happy I don't know yeah or or
it's a prototype build issue
um
right you know it works but it works for
just regular text
yeah I I'm not surprised that this might
be uh a hole in undo and I don't think
it's very difficult to plug
right right I don't think I don't think
there's anything deep here
right yeah I'm just pointing out that
like with uh you know with equal or with
uh greater than for natural language
cells you can sort of you know you can
just hit back or go through another
couple of equals and get back to where
you started but if if we're going to
replace it with a non-empty cell then
it's not
you're not going to get back to where
you started
because style key mapping only affects
an empty cell so
it's you know it's going to be a
somewhat different user experience I
don't understand what are you saying I
mean you've got it okay so type in you
know in the in in between some
insertions type in grader
okay
should show the type of language it's
expecting go ahead all right so now if
you
um
I type two plus two and then I have
enough for some reason the python
appeared and now I do command Z and now
I'm beeping
and you're saying that's wrong I should
be able to back out of this great
Advanced side
um well I'm saying you could have backed
out of it even earlier like if you had
let me finish you're not understanding
what I'm saying go ahead go ahead go
ahead go ahead go ahead so you know you
start you right so follow what I'm
actually telling you to do so you know
like type back here
type what what do you want
backspace or delete whatever it's called
okay right see you you can undo that
because the cell is still empty
whereas you couldn't do that
if you if the replacement created a
non-empty cell so that's going to be
I'm totally confused what what so it's I
mean it's not a problem with the way
that undo Works internally uh I'm not
talking about undo anymore
I'm talking about the user experience
right you can cycle through input to
equal to double equals to input just by
pressing the equal sign right if
right okay but but you can't you if if
at any point that created a non-empty
cell it would stop the cycle because
equal style key mapping only works when
you have an empty cell
and so this new syntax where you replace
it with a whole cell that has stuff in
it
is is sort of going to break that idiom
which so well and to be clear it the you
know the old version isn't going away
and it would be the preferred version to
use for empty cells so so this is uh
this is only something that's useful
when for some reason you're populating a
cell in some way in which case yeah you
won't be able to cycle through anymore
you still be able to do this like look
unless you've typed nothing into the
cell
it's only when you've typed nothing into
the cell that triple equals gives you an
empty cell again
as soon as you type something into the
cell typing more equal signs does the
kind of thing I just did exactly so so
so maybe a practical sort of uh
implication is taking the equal bracket
case that if uh if you type in equal it
will convert to Wolfram Alpha short if
you type in bracket it would convert to
an input cell with equal bracket
populated and then if you type backspace
you will still have an input cell
um with a leading with a leading equal
sign
and I I agree it's maybe you know it's
maybe slightly weird but I frankly I'm
I'm not really bothered by that let's
let's one you have it built let's play
with it and see what it feels like okay
I'm I'm just you know it's a good point
my concern is yeah I got it I finally
understood what you're talking about yes
okay
all right let's move on item input okay
so this was something I discovered
actually when I was composing this
agenda uh so item and sub item and Sub
sub item have corresponding Styles item
paragraph sub item paragraph sub item
paragraph
um and these styles are basically text
cells
but text cells that line up with the
items so they don't out dense you know
they look like they're part of the item
kind of going on
yes we don't have a similar sort of
concept for input cells so if your item
has kind of you know extra baggage that
it wants to accumulate that looks like
you know that is an input cell
it there's no way to do that just
outdense like the first example there
and and the output also out if you
evaluate that all the outputs you're
saying that this here that the message
will not be indented here
oh for God's freaking sake why is it
doing this again
I don't know it's been reported already
and they are working on it who's working
on it oh well people friends Arnold and
Roger or Julia
um and they were supposed to uninstall
uh something tools to to see if that was
of courseware tools I think it was
um
what did that do well this is a
prototype number where do I reset this
what do I uh it's in the options Vector
it's not it's not in the preferences
right now
really should be
well we talked about that too yes you
you submitted that as a suggestion
um where is it uh search for message
options
it'll have to be global
uh and then yeah kernel message action
is set to print to console who knows why
if you just check the X next to it it
will revert itself back to the you know
default
print to notebook which is what it's
supposed to be yeah which is what it was
supposed to be yeah and this is
something we've been seeing on your
system for ages and we don't know why
um
um it's got to be something you have
installed locally and that's what our
node has been trying to run down okay
all right uh but but in any case I mean
you know see the difference in at the
message cell and the print cell and the
output cell as well I've actually been
happening to me too and I don't know if
I've been running some code that's
causing it to happen but I've had the
same thing so okay well then go debug it
please
okay
so I don't understand the points here
so put a put a bullet right above that
the inner five
okay like this and and now you know the
the the uh the input now group doesn't
it yeah it's uh
so it doesn't look like it's part you
know sometimes you have you know your
items have more information that you
want to be part of the items it's kind
of you know it's it's it's kind of a
nested outline sort of thing
yeah so it's a multicellular item where
the item is the head cell and what we're
saying here is right now
right now the the sub cells here are not
indenting yeah correct but why do you
want a separate style won't that be
totally confusing if you copy that cell
somewhere else it'll do something
ridiculous
well so the problem is that what happens
after you finish your bulleted list
um I mean you know so and input so after
your bulleted list could be part of the
last bullet
or it could be
you know the next thing after the
bulleted list
right I don't even know how to get it to
be the the thing after so so the same
problem already happens with text cells
okay and the way it's solved and has
been solved for many many years with
textiles is a new style was added and
the style is called item paragraph
which is what
which is the thing that indents as if
it's still part of the bullet yes and
how do I get to it it's in the style
menu
it's been there since like version four
or something
maybe five
um but is there any way that I can get
to it I mean in other words if I'm if
I'm writing bulleted text so here's a
question
yeah I don't think there is no keyboard
shortcut for it okay that's what you're
asking I've got a suggestion right one
thing that I often want is I'm writing
text and I'm basically having one
paragraph per cell
okay yeah I have no convenient way to
jump to the new cell
you know other than I finish I click I
start a new cell
my question would be should there be
something like a command return or
something
which well so so there is right now and
uh oh uh you can define a cell style in
such a way that when you press enter it
will automatically create a new cell in
that style
um and that's I believe that's used in
docu tools authoring well it's also used
in normal text cells
you can just option enter to create a
new cell of the current Style
right so if you wow
cool asaurus well that's the thing
that's probably been there for 35 years
and I didn't know it yeah yeah
an item behaves the way John was
describing that enter is just
gives you the new cell
a new item cell anyway so so if you just
create a new item cell and then type
something and press enter you'll get
another item so in other words making a
multi-line item is not really a thing
right
whoops
whoops what the hell happened okay
oh yeah
that's a little confusing but I guess
that that makes sense but so if I now go
option
enter I just got another one of those
which is fine
yeah
I didn't know that option Hunter did
that has that been the case but since
version one uh I don't know one but two
I think yeah it's it's in the insert
menu
uh it's called sell with same style
oh well
it's like the third item in the insert
menu too
yeah so
so it is
what do you know okay it's a reason for
continuing education so to speak of all
of us and our users
yeah
okay all right so what's the question
here
uh okay so uh so if you look in uh the
format style Sub menu
so you'll see that we have
um
item and item paragraph uh that was
pre-existing in this notebook I actually
created a private style sheet which adds
item inputs okay
um and so basically that's what I'm
suggesting is that we have item input
and sub item input and Sub sub item
input and in in 14 because these things
will get a little cluttery uh in 14
we're working on a way to to aggregate
these things into uh submenus so maybe
we might you know push off a bunch of
these things
sub item is just an indebted item so
press so type type a star and then press
tab
that sub item
and if you do tab again it's Sub sub
item
and you can backspace to get back to the
previous level of indent which is yeah
um either backspace or shift tab either
one works what about the delete now
delete now is looking to do anything
because that is the base yeah
right
okay
okay and in fact I use these Styles in
the last agenda item I I like this so
much so
yeah itai was also initially a bit
confused when I when I explained this to
him but yes I I think it's something
that that you know for people who know
that it's there at least I think is
something that will catch another thing
I'd like to put in the user assistant
let me do okay something that's
initially going to sound crazy
which is the fact that I don't know that
option return makes a new cell
right if you actually watched everything
I did
in
kind of uh
um
what am I trying to say you know
everything I did and typing into a
notebook and you were an ai-ish thing
you could readily say hey why aren't you
using option whatever why are you using
this five keystroke combo when you could
be doing this
um
so
uh
something I want to discuss in user
assistance
I mean I have no idea how one would even
collect a train set on that sort of data
I know I don't think it's a machine
learning problem I think it's a it's a
not a machine well but the point being I
don't think that that at it's at GPT
understands any better than you know
then
anything we could even train because
it's just that kind of data just isn't
out there I mean it's it would have to
be something like an expert writes up
you know all of your friends
right I mean it's like a lot of our
other rule-based things
you know what I'm saying it's a Notifier
if you see this key combination do this
I think it's worth thinking about
think that there might be 10 of them
that would really improve a bunch of
user workflows
so I'm saying yeah
okay this is pretty straightforward we
already have information of notebook
objects I'm just proposing
um uh information of cell objects and
you can see basically the list of rules
that we that we have at the moment
looks reasonable except for the fact
that this font is too big
isn't that well it's not that that's the
normal font of a data object right that
yeah so it's probably not right in this
case because this isn't the normal font
of a text cell is it
well you're also not in a text so I know
and and this is not this doesn't look
right
it looks way too big
right well yes well I guess that's what
happens when people insist on hard
coding font sizes
okay so I'm saying how do we fix that
I'll take a look at it
sorry who said that what Nick
okay
yeah it's probably that it should be
using an ambient font size and it's not
uh dude well maybe we should take a look
at what are the Avail available things
and I mean we could just sort of stick
uh
everything there in the in in the
information but I'm not sure that's
necessarily right uh that's a known
prototype build issue it wouldn't show
up in a
regular nightly build but it's in the
Prototype build and it's on my list to
fix
right but when I do this
does this do something sensible
yes it does it sends that yeah that
string in there yeah do we get a bunch
of these
uh yeah
yeah get a decent amount
would you like them from me because I
don't send them in
um the uh there of less practical value
on nightly builds because uh because the
form doesn't track the Providence of
what build it only tracks version number
it doesn't track like you know which
build number generated this so
so for you know uh uh for builds that
are not production builds it means that
we get
um you know yeah a bunch of crap because
it's you know something that was a bug
and then it went away yep no that's not
the latest version of the agenda I
wonder what happened there but
um
can we can we actually look at the thing
I asked to look at which is not notebook
cell data but actually look at the cell
information and think a little bit about
what goes it actually goes in
information that's that's not that's a
notebook object
I'm sorry what are you saying are we
looking at this item here inflation of
cell objects yes and I'm saying look at
the next cell which actually has
information
right the the point of this thing is
cell object not notebook object
and so
that right that is the available
information for uh
okay you're saying
I'm saying ignore that yeah okay so this
is the wrong thing what what was really
once oh
well it's showing for example we support
information of notebook object right now
but we don't yet support information as
cell object that's the proposal that we
begin doing so and the starting point
for what might be in it could be the
output of developer back to excel
information
sounds reasonable to me I don't know the
details well that's why I'm asking that
we look at it Stephen so maybe put a
slash slash column at the at the next
guy and uh evaluate that then we can
take a look
um I mean so I mean style obviously
um
in a form where we can just like see
let's just say data set Association
um
names are a bit weird sure yeah I I mean
you know these names were done ages and
ages ago I'm I'm not generally attached
to uh to most of the names well it's
rendering it needs rendering
um so rendering
um is uh you know I'm not actually 100
certain that's totally relevant it may
be from the post Crypt days uh I'll have
to check to see if it still maps to
Modern Graphics but okay but but it was
the notion that that a cell is in the
process of being drawn or that you know
it's it's not uh you know it needs to be
redrawn uh that's in principle what it
meant but PostScript had a very kind of
specific notion of how to do this and
that might date from those days all
right so this just needs some
monetization I mean sell serial number
we now have cell IDs right uh that
actually is cell ID
okay is it wait wait is sorry excuse me
uh no no I'm gonna retract that no
actually I don't think it is I that
might be the
um
someone just on the creation order in
this session except
2071 isn't what I would have expected uh
okay so I I'm I I actually I don't
remember and I would have to go look
that up I don't want to waste your time
doing that here
okay um needs some modernization
basically concept seems fine needs
modernization right and content data is
a pretty important one which you might
not like the name for but it is it is
the type of the cell you know
cell type don't we have other names for
this in other places
this seems uncooked here this seems like
there's more work that can be done it's
not you know these names seem kind of
cruddy
and and do we so for example the
um
yes and there's also the question of do
we want to include all of these things
so for example is formatted something we
want to include is cursor position
something we want to include yes
um why wouldn't
well it it's sort of very time dependent
I mean right so so evaluate the next
example
right so
[Music]
um
and then if you yeah
right so if you click around you get
moving different positions and if you
can click right above or right below the
cell
yeah and if you'd like the right thing
to me I mean being able to say Dynamic
of information of evaluation cell seems
like a good thing formatted by the way
is if you toggle the cell expression on
the side yeah so if you if you yeah
exactly if you do shift command D on the
input cell then
it'll it'll show up as unformatted
yeah yeah
and so is that something again is that
something we want to include maybe yes
okay yes
um so I I I I I think if I'm
understanding any ties you know sort of
meta concern uh correctly it's that you
know information here is maybe returning
things that seem a bit more ephemeral
than the typical information I see yes
exactly ephemeral is usually more you
know summary information and this is a
bit more or like current value
yes
um and uh and not noticed that I have
and also noticed that I had to manually
Force Dynamic updating in order to get
this I get it Dynamic is not
automatically paying attention to the
fact that some information could update
yeah
and I bet it shouldn't because I bet
that can lead to some horrifying
slowdown somewhere yes
definitely
well so the issue is should these things
be in current value or should they be an
information of cell cell expression cell
a value of information of cell object
well and so generally you know if we
have kind of a philosophy of what sort
of things should be an information or
cell object than then I think we can
make a bunch of these decisions you know
ourselves
so what are you saying
uh
in other words guiding principle if we
have a guiding principle of what should
be in here then you know then we don't
have to kind of micromanage every single
thing because you know Lou and I can
kind of apply The Guiding principles
appropriately
I do tend to think that your point about
not putting ephemeral things into
information seems sensible to me
but
I mean look or alternatively said
information is a one and done thing
which if you want to make it Dynamic you
have to put go to effort like putting
the update into Poland
and it can it can pull out things that
are ephemeral
at the time when it asks for them
if you get what I'm saying
okay
yeah you don't have the ephemeral stuff
we'll be all is arguing oh but you could
change the style
so it it should be noted if we look at
the information of notebook object there
are there are a couple of ephemeral
fields in there
you know the the memory modification
file modification modified memory I I
think there's a slippery slope here now
what should be provided as a current
value
is a different thing that can certainly
overlap with what's in information yeah
all right
I was just looking at a pull request for
that today actually so yeah there
there's a uh yeah there is there there's
a futurized ref page for that uh I don't
know what happened with uh
yeah the Stephen Stephen just uh uh
resized a notebook or something it'll
and that will fix it up
there you go
and if this is a prototype build the
inputs in that draft ref page will work
so this is the history
stuff to to remind you that the
evolution of the notebook history
dialogue into uh system function
that's a lot of thinking that that's
pinking that's what it's worth
so yes there's a data set issue that I
need to chat with you tie about but we
don't need to take up space for that in
this meeting
um but so you've seen this function once
before at the time was called notebook
cell information and there were a couple
of things you didn't like about it
including some of its options
um so what's currently in the Prototype
build is the thing documented here which
resolves the issues that you had with it
namely the the name which you request to
be notebook cell data
and the two options which are described
at the bottom of the details section
there still exist I don't know if they
need to they might not need to
um
nothing but they are they're not method
options yes
I don't think we need this
was it one uh is this thing not aligned
properly
so it's not aligned properly
interval type setting yep
okay so one questions with a cell object
should have a print form
well it does have a print so it does
okay
I can't imagine we need this
well what are these things here those
are the
why is there a key in this Association
why is it not
because that's the actual cell
yes and if you were to uh you know the
unfortunate thing about data set well I
know you can try clicking on you know
the the cell style that should be a link
but you may need to copy
the cell object out of it because it's a
because of data set
why isn't this just a list where this is
like sell content or something
why is what not a list
why is this not a data set of a list
rather than it is that the thing with
keys where the keys are the cells I mean
the cells are in a definite order right
this function can take lists of cell
objects
it doesn't just point at notebook
objects in which as you say the cells
have a definite order you can give it
lists of cell objects in any order you
like what happens if I repeat a cell
object in that list
then it will do something but cell
objects are unique right so it'll drop
right like the association drops things
right
um but what I'm asking is why not just
return a list
of
associations that represent each cell
that include
and then when you ask for it for
you know a collection of cells you just
get a list of results a list of
associations as results
rather than the data set
oh and it can be a data set but instead
of a list I'm just saying I don't think
the key being the cell object is
terribly useful I
I don't understand why not
why you don't think it's useful
Stephen are you saying you just want the
cell object to be a value and there to
be a key that gives that column that's
what I'm suggesting
that it's a list of
essentially I mean
I mean all right whether whether it's a
key or not I still think it should be
the First Column sure I don't disagree
about that but I mean yes I think it
should be the First Column but to what
extent
is the cell thing we've just looked at
the cell information function
information of cell object
to what extent is that recapitulating
so the items that are available in cell
information will also be available as
targets for Notebook cell data as things
you can ask for from notebook cell data
as is any current value or any option
name
all right so there's defaults here but
but now is there anything in cell
notebook cell data that's not accessible
from cell or information of cell object
yes for instance any current value font
size for instance
and there are also some custom elements
that you can ask for like cell thumbnail
that goes off and does you know some new
thing or cell image which just
rasterizes the thing you're asking for I
mean notebook cell data allows you to
specify
lots of things that you might want you
might want the cell expression and why
does population sell object not also
allow these things
for one thing it's because it doesn't
exist at the moment
um but if you're saying we should just
uh
um some of these things are not
information about the cell they're
computed Things based on the cell
right cell image
is not you know it's not a feature of
the cell
it's a processed
is are we seeing all of the default
columns
um
so
[Music]
um
so what we I don't know what we're
looking at in the agenda I'm sorry this
is a resource why can't we scroll over
in a data set
it wasn't one of those buttons
how do I do it well you're it's the data
set is wider than the notebook you
scroll The Notebook
okay
data set without scrolling The Notebook
please delete this output we should not
be looking at this output we should be
looking at the draft ref page
this output is from resource a function
that is no longer the ground Truth for
what this function is going to become
but the response to respond to the
student's question yes sometimes you
need the two scrollers to see the whole
data set
for a while we're putting a scroller in
the reset itself
in order to do that you have to know how
wide you have to actually prescribe how
wide the data set is
but but sometimes even with this color
in the data set you still need to move
both
but but wait a second John
you don't need to prescribe what you're
saying is with that scroller you are
changing the left margin in the data set
see what I'm saying
you're just saying that whatever is at
the left hand side isn't the left but
but how how wide does the The Blob that
is the screen you know the the on-screen
rectangle that holds the the data set
how wide is that if it's not the full
width of the data set you have to
specify a width no no it's the width
okay look what's visible on the screen
if I were to get back this thing that I
just deleted
okay
[Music]
um
you can just evaluate those two cells or
yeah that works if I get this back right
what I'm saying is
right now if I had a scroller within the
data set itself it would just get it to
the point where for example this is on
the left hand side of the of the visible
uh sub window that is the data set and
and what's the rightmost column
where is the right Edge
the right Edge is at the right edge of
the notebook it's cut off as it is right
now
it's cut off but all that's happening is
this
oh I see it's it's cut off because it
Scrolls off to the right yeah okay so
you're saying that this scroller is
doing the exact same thing I thought
that scroller might scroll the whole
notebook it does but it only Scrolls
things which are cut off to the right
exactly
that seems like the right Behavior
Jose did you still have a different
thing to say on that
I've seen cases and I think this has
been reported that that there is a
scroller in the data set and another one
in the notebook and the users wanted
that
see the data set with the scroller in
the data set and you have to use the one
in The Notebook
I I I I I don't know what basis the data
set code uses for deciding whether to
have an internal scroller but but the
front end doesn't care anything about
dataset the front end has a thing of a
certain width and if that width is wider
than the window it's going to scroll it
guys I really need to take off here
um
uh
do we still have to look over this
well I mean how much review does uh
notebook cell data need to go into 14 as
a you know at least get it get it in the
and let's look at it one more time okay
and did we decide to go on YouTube I
mean I think Stephen did raise the
interesting question of what is the
relationship between notebook cell data
and information of cell
I mean in principle since we're I mean I
I suppose while I'm not sure what all
the keys are I because I I've not
memorized this documentation
um but there is an item a line the
second detail there says anything from
cell information you can get to with
notebook cell data
whether whether the opposite
you know whether that needs to be true
in cell information
well is it ever the case that
information
can give you uh uh things that don't
exist in the kind of single argument
form of information so you know you do
information of an object and then you do
information of an object comma key is
there ever a key that wasn't shown in
the initial in the initial view yeah for
entities it is you can ask for
information of France and it will give
you a summary but you can ask for any
property that's in any value and it'll
return it okay
and do we consider that a good design
could you repeat what you just said
that's debatable yeah if you do entity
value of entity country France you will
get
I'm sorry information of entity country
France you will get a set of summary
properties giving you basic information
about France that you can ask for a
property that's in any value which is
not in the information list itself and
we will still fetch it for you
that's done as a convenience so that we
don't say oh we have the information
about France's population we're just not
going to give it to you because you
asked information instead of entity
value
it's a little bit weird but I think it's
okay
right and so then the question is do we
need
uh right so then John is raising the
point of if we settle on just having
um
information of
uh
um
of cell object then
well I suppose well I suppose the reason
we need the cell information data is
that it accepts things other than just a
single cell object or even a list of
cell Optics right you can give it a
notebook I know can you give it like a
selection or other fancy things no
just a notebook object or cell objects
right
yeah so I guess right I guess the reason
we want the cell information data is
that
um
you know it it can also understand
notebook objects and then we can uh
um
uh
[Music]
um
you know
then it can do the right thing so
you know maybe John and I should just
take another look at exactly what we
want out of information and this and you
know we can sign off at the next meeting
hopefully fine okay okay last item of
that in code string I like transcode
is quite good
the only question is should it be string
transcript or transcode string
because it both takes in a string gives
out a string
I kind of slightly prefer transcode
string but is that consistent
um okay so I didn't realize that video
did it in the opposite order
um that may be a
good reason to go that way I'm not sure
that it is okay
why oh there we go yeah beautiful look
at how magnificent this fuzzy completion
stuff is
magnificent
um
right but yeah for other things like you
know for other things actually no I do
like Trends code string better because
well no uh like I like it I like it much
better but I can't I can't articulate
why yeah I also like it much better
right so we have like base encode base
decode
which
sort of suggests it should be string
transcode
um I mean we have pure transliterate
that's true
I think transcode string is the right
thing I think transcode on its own is
too weird
right there's there's a little bit of
you know this weirdness and uh
I'm having a bit of trouble coming up
with a usage message but maybe that
maybe John and I can work on that
offline and be happy to do so
that's a good string of that thing there
transcodes from Unicode to utf-8 is that
correct
uh well it I mean it transcodes from the
the kind of you know native encoding of
strings I I I I hesitate to refer to
that as Unicode but
okay I think that's very reasonable
transcode string to utf-8 sounds very
reasonable to me
okay
all right let's wrap it up thanks a lot
guys see you all soon okay thank you bye